okay
hmm
yes
uh
um
[Music]
is
like
all of us
[Music]
is
um
i need a photo
so
hey
good morning
before i start
i'd like to report that later today i'll
be signing the bill
funding the government operations for
the next few months
funding the government isn't a great
achievement
it's a bare minimum what we need to get
done but
in these times a bipartisan cooperation
is worth recognition so i want to thank
senator schumer and mcconnell and
speaker pelosi for getting this done
and i want to thank a substantial
bipartisan vote in the senate for
sending this bill to my desk today to
avoid disruptions of government
operations
and i want to urge congress to use the
time this bill provides to work toward a
bipartisan agreement on a full-year
funding bill
that makes the needed investments in our
economy and our people from public
health education to national security
now for today's news
every year december brings the joys of
the holiday season and gives us an
opportunity to reflect on the year gone
by
and look ahead and begin to imagine the
new year to come
this year we can reflect on an
extraordinary bit of progress
our economy is markedly stronger than it
was a year ago
and today the incredible news that our
unemployment rate has fallen to 4.2
percent
at this point in the year we're looking
at the sharpest one-year decline in
unemployment ever
simply put
america america is back to work
and our jobs recovery is going very
strong
today's historic drop in unemployment
rate includes dramatic improvements for
workers who have often seen higher wages
and higher levels of unemployment excuse
me higher levels of unemployment they
are receiving higher wages and the rate
of black and hispanic unemployment is
also dropping sharply
but that's not just jobs that are up
wages are up especially for hardworking
americans often ignored in the past
and past recovers
workers in transportation and warehouses
have seen their wages go up
approximately 10 percent this year
workers hotels and restaurants have seen
their wages go up 13 this year
and thanks to american rescue plan we've
delivered significant tax cuts to
families raising children
tax cuts and raising wages for middle
class families
meaning that americans on average have
more in their pockets today than they
did
each
month since we've been in office than
they did last year after accounting for
inflation
let me repeat that even after accounting
for rising prices the typical american
family has more money in their pockets
than they did last year
in fact we're the only leading economy
in the world for household income
and the economy as a whole
are stronger than they were before the
pandemic
applications for new small businesses
are up 30 percent compared to before the
pandemic
thanks to the american rescue plan
were cutting child poverty in america by
more than 40 percent
and millions of children who spent last
christmas in poverty will not bear that
burden this holiday season
and today's news means that unemployment
rate has now fallen by more than two
percentage points since i took office
that's the fastest decline in a single
year on record that's about three times
faster than any other president in their
first year in office
the number of people claiming
unemployment has fallen from 18 million
when i took office to 2 million this
week another record drop
we've also learned today that in
november 235 000 jobs were created in
the private sector
and when they went back and recalibrated
they found the last two months they
found that job growth over the prior two
months september and october
actually created 82 000 more jobs than
previously been reported
which means that
we've averaged nearly 400 000 new jobs a
month over the last three months a solid
pace
all told
in the first 10 full months of my
administration the economy has created
six million jobs a record for a new
president
this is a significant improvement from
when i took office in january a sign
that we're on the right track
because the extraordinary strides we've
made we can look forward to a brighter
happier new year ahead in my view
but i also know that despite this
progress families are anxious they're
anxious about covet they're anxious
about the cost of living the economy
more broadly they're still uncertain
i want you to know i hear you
it's not enough to know that we're
making progress
you need to see it and feel it in your
own lives around the kitchen table in
your checkbooks
and that's why
every day my team and i are working to
deliver consistent determined focused
action to overcome the challenges we
still face
a chief among those challenges is covet
19.
yesterday
i laid out key actions we're going to
take this winner to fight this virus to
protect one another to protect our
economy and our economic recovery they
include
number one expanding our nationwide
booster campaign
with more outreach more appointments and
more
hours i was thrilled to see that
yesterday we had more vaccine shots
administered than any day in the past
six months
number two
we're launching hundreds of new family
vaccination clinics to make it easier
for children parents the whole family to
get vaccinated in one place
and new policies to keep children in
school instead of guaranteeing them at
home when someone in the class comes
down with covet if they do
thirdly
making free at-home tests more available
than ever before
by having them covered by our private
health insurance plans
the availability of community health
centers and other sites for the
uninsured will be the alternative as
well so if you have insurance you're
going to
cover these these tests and if you don't
have insurance we have facilities you
can attend and get these tests
increasing our surge responses of
forcing our surge response teams
they're made up of doctors and nurses
and medical staff
who go into communities with rising
cases and provide the needed staff for
overrun hospitals
for their emergency rooms their
intensive care units to get help to them
as they need it and we're about tripling
the number of those surge teams
accelerate fifth we're accelerating our
efforts to vaccinate the rest of the
world and strengthening international
travel rules for people coming into the
united states
this is a plan all americans can
rally behind in my view
we're also addressing another concern
for families
just about every country is grappling
with high prices right now
as they fight the pandemic
as the world economy continues to come
back to life
the more for the more price pressures
are gonna
ease as things begin to move
but we're not sitting around waiting
in the meantime i've used every tool
available to address price increases
and it's beginning to work
take gasoline and gas prices
last week i announced the largest ever
release from the united states strategic
petroleum reserve to increase the supply
of oil and help bring down prices
and i brought together other countries
india japan the republic of korea the
united kingdom
who all agreed
all agreed to join me in releasing
additional oil from their reserves and
china
china may very do well do do more as
well they haven't done it yet
this worldwide effort we're leading
won't solve the problem of high gas
prices overnight
but over the last month
likely due in part to the anticipation
of this action
we've seen oil and gas prices out of the
wells
oil and gas prices on the wholesale
market come down significantly
since the end of october actually the
average weekly price of gasoline on the
wholesale market
that's what you sell to the gas stations
has fallen around 10
and that decline has picked up in recent
days
that's a drop of about 25 cents per
gallon
these savings are beginning to reach
americans and should pick up in the
weeks ahead
and it can't happen fast enough
and i've asked the federal trade
commission
to consider
whether potentially illegal and
anti-competitive behavior in the oil and
gas industry is causing higher prices
for consumers when they don't need to be
that high because
the wholesale prices come down so much
so we can ensure that the american
people are paying a fair price for gas
at this time
of the year another concern is facing
american families is about being able to
find what you need in the holidays
whether it's gifts or groceries
as i let earlier in the week
because of my actions the actions of my
administration has taken
in partnership with bisma excuse me with
private business and labor
retailers
and grocery stores freight movers and
railroads
these shelves are going to be the
shelves of our stores are going to be
well stocked
we've sped up operations at our ports
for example at the port of los angeles
and long beach
the two busiest ports in america over
the last month the number of containers
left sitting on the docks for over eight
days is now by 40 percent i've said that
before and people companies said well
what does that mean and so they're
down 40 well it means that the product
are no longer sitting on the docks
they're getting off the docks
in the trains into trucks into me into
vehicles to get them to the store
shelves
this is an incredible success story
on monday i convened a group of ceos
from some of the largest retailers in
grocery stores as well as leading
companies that works with small
businesses across the country
and they reported that their investments
are up
shelves are well stocked
and they're ready to meet consumer
demand for the holidays
now i said that yesterday and i saw a
couple of your stations put on you found
some empty shelves
they're old empty shelves but it doesn't
matter but go back and take a look at
some of those shelves again okay
but the the point is with the vast
majority of the shells are filled and
the ceos of
not only the
the the suppliers but the ceos of ups
and fedex which are on track to deliver
more packages than ever
are saying the same thing
so we're heading into holiday season in
strong shape
again this is about a concerted focused
action
we averted this potential crisis by
figuring out what needed to be fixed
and then we brought together the people
of the capacity to fix it or at least
alleviate it
now now it's time to build on the
success we had this year on jobs
wages creation of more small businesses
fixing challenges in the economy
and we need to cut costs further for
families
that's what my buildback better plan
does is still be considered in congress
it will lower the out-of-pocket cost for
child care
elder care
housing
college health care prescription drugs
in fact a new independent analysis
released this week showed that my plan
would mean
7 400 in tax cuts and savings for the
typical family of four with two children
17 nobel prize winners in economics have
written a letter to me affirming that
this bill would reduce long-term
inflationary pressures in the economy
and two of the leading
rating agencies not not
you know liberal think tanks
two of the leading rating agencies on
wall street
confirmed this month that my plan will
not add to inflationary pressures
what i've always proposed in my
proposing now is have a way of lower
lower some of the most difficult costs
and what are they
the difficult costs families pay every
month
by asking corporations and wealthiest
americans including for example the 55
corporations page zero and federal
income tax last year
despite generating 40 billion dollars in
profits and i'm happy they're profitable
to begin to pay their fair share
for example
just requiring corporations to pay a
minimum 15 percent
in taxes
raises enough revenue
to pay for lowering the cost of child
care
for 90 percent of families
and provides universal preschool for
three and for all three and
four-year-olds in america
now what's better for those corporations
is it better for them having child care
so parents can come back to work today
and they have a better educated
workforce in the future
or keep having not paying any tax
once again no one no one making less
than four hundred thousand dollars a
year will pay a penny more in federal
taxes
my build back better plan is fiscally
responsible
it's the first major piece of
legislation in more than a decade
that's not only fully paid for
but will generate more than 100 billion
dollars in deficit reduction this decade
it fully covers the cost of its
investments but making the largest
corporations and richest americans pay a
little more in taxes
i think that's a trade-off that's worth
making
and by the way those very businesses are
going to do better having a better
educated and more available workforce
having those who've done very well pay
their fair share
is just the right thing to do in order
to provide a little breathing room for
millions of american families
throughout our history
we've emerged from crisis by investing
in ourselves
and so we're going to keep at this
we're going to keep making progress for
our families and for our nation
i promise you that's what's going to
happen
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops and keep everyone safe
mr president
mr president
uh your voice sounds a little different
are you okay i'm okay i have a test
every day to see a cover test i have a
checkpoint for all the strands what i
have is a one and a half year old
grandson who had a cold who likes to
kiss his pop
and he's been kissing my anyway so uh
but it's just a call and then so on
government policy it seems like
the administration is starting to soften
some of the language there's this new
op-ed where you talk about
uh covenant we're going to beat it back
are you no longer going to shut it down
no we got to beat it back before we shut
it down look it's going to take time
worldwide in order to be covered we have
to shut it down worldwide
in the united states of america we're
doing everything that needs to be done
to take care of the american people
within our borders but look what's
happened you know we're starting to make
some real progress and you find out
there's another strain and the idea that
you can build a wall
around america to keep any kova from
around the world out is not not there
and besides
that's one of the reasons why i know
we get criticized now you're criticized
for not doing more for the world
we've done more for the world and
providing vaccines available and help
than any nation all every other nation
in the world combined
in addition to that in addition to that
we've also with regard to india and
other countries and we're working around
the clock remember i suggest that we
suspend the patents
let everybody be able to have access to
this so they can make the vaccine in
their own countries and thirdly
in southern africa
for example south africa has all the
vaccines they need they don't want any
more vaccines now one of the things i'm
considering is how can we help them
deal with the issue of
uh the as i said before when the biggest
challenge
we had in the beginning of this
administration in my view was not
getting the vaccines
produced although that was not easy and
i've got to give you know president
trump
early on went out and tried to guide
them to do the research to try to get
the right vaccines
but logistically
logistically
getting the vaccine from a container
that gets delivered to you to a hospital
to a state to you and getting in
someone's arms that's a very very
difficult thing
and we did it better than anybody in the
world that's done it but we've got to
try to help other people
thank you mr president given that there
are now
multiple cases of omicron here in the
u.s are you considering requiring
vaccines for domestic travel or any
other new measures for domestic travel
the
measures
that i announced yesterday
are we believe are sufficient
to deal with
the proper
medical precautions to deal with the
spread of this new variant
we are doing as you know
at nih as well as
among the manufacturers a lot of
research to see the extent of its how
quickly it spreads how deadly it is etc
etc but we do require for travel we're
going to continue to require the people
to have masks on
masks on and in public places and so and
federal buildings so but i don't at this
point because let me
i think i know a fair amount about this
issue but i'm not a scientist
so i continue to rely on the scientists
and asking them whether or not we have
to move beyond what we did yesterday
right now they're saying no
[Music]
[Music]
what is what is happening in ukraine and
what on the border between ukraine and
russia and what are you going to do
about it
i have been in
constant contact
with our
allies
in europe
with the ukrainians
my secretary of state the national
security advisor have been engaged
extensively
and
what i am doing is putting together
what i believe to be
will be the most comprehensive and uh
meaningful set of
initiatives to make it very very
difficult
for mr putin to uh
to go ahead and do what people are
worried he may do but that's in play
right now
[Music]
our vaccine is holding you in dr john
are you going to talk to mr president
did you talk to him this morning mr
president no